guillaume bigot merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors ce soir
on le disait le lancement de la mission
d'information avec l'audition du premier
ministre et du ministre de la santé
samedi dernier les deux hommes ont donné
une conférence de presse avec beaucoup
de détails et de précision alors est ce
qu'on est en train d'assister à une
véritable transparence du gouvernement
ou plutôt un exercice de communication
est pas incompatible on regarde la
communication en étant transparent
on peut simplement noté qu'il y a une
énorme énorme différence entre le ton
martial voir autoritarisme du président
de la république
linky finalement tente de dissimuler
probablement une forme de conclusion et
de gênes et le ton beaucoup plus mesurée
beaucoup plus humble aussi de d'edouard
philippe et d'olivier ferrand alors
qu'on peut regretter que le pouvoir en
général mais la critique est aisée l'art
est difficile bien sûr court après les
événements et finalement maintenant
aujourd'hui reconnaître est heureux
qu'il y a eu des erreurs et que on le
sent bien de manière tout à fait sincère
certes m toute la machine étatique franc
pèse tout le système de santé trop fait
et l'exécutif est mobilisé pour faire au
mieux et l'exercice consiste à rendre
compte au plus juste en plus près de
manière humble et sincère
bon c'est un exercice et qu'il la seule
chose c'est qu'on peut dire que cette
sorte de deux malades auxquels son
registre eux de ce qui se passe on n'a
pour l'instant pas de vision sur la
presse pas de cap pas de stratégie alors
on ne peut pas tout savoir c'est ce qu'a
dit ce soir le premier ministre edouard
philippe parce que justement le
gouvernement a intérêt à révéler ses
failles notamment pendant pendant cette
commission dans cette mission oui je
pense qu'il a intérêt de raisons la
première part que tout va finir par se
dénouer ce savoir et et qu'en réalité le
seul intérêt à ne pas jouer cartes sur
table c'est jeudi le seul intérêt de ce
prêt de maintenir une certaine forme ou
de de confiance mais si on réfléchit
bien le lien de confiance et l'autorité
de l'état et tout autour
d'ailleurs dans sa parole est lié ou à
l'établissement de cette confiance au
maintien à l'entretien fait confiance or
si on ne sent pas finalement une parole
d'autorité pas consisté à dire est que
les nous ne savons pas tout et pour pour
les préfets d'entendre des dirigeants
virent nous ne savons pas tout alors que
tout le monde voit bien qu'ils ne savent
pas tout et qu'il se sont envoyés ces
matches qui ne servait à rien les
commandes par milliards donc il était
temps de le reconnaître mais c'est une
parole finalement rassurante
en réalité je pense que tu avais
peut-être un peu corporatiste la haute
fonction publique qui était aux manettes
à la tête de l'exécutif depuis très
longtemps en france
c'est un réflexe corporatiste consistant
à considérer que coop est un grand
enfant
on doit pas pu lui dire pour leurs
assurés d'une certaine façon et ce n'est
pas rassurant du tout donc
paradoxalement ils avouent leur
ignorance kidal où leurs lignes et au
contraire à mon avis extrêmement
rassurant on a vu aussi des dirigeants
français beaucoup consulté les experts a
notamment au début de la crise à ce que
c'était une bonne stratégie de la part
du gouvernement selon vous non et à
nouveau pour dragon dictate la première
est que les experts ne sont jamais
d'accord entre eux il ya un philosophe
gaston bachelard qui a beaucoup réfléchi
à l'histoire des fientes
elle avait cette formule la vérité est
une suite d'erreurs rectifier la vérité
scientifique est une étude est rectifié
vous ne trouverez pas 2 d'experts qui
sont d'accord entre eux
donc quand bien même vous voulez vous
reposer sur la parole des experts l
expert art l expert bethel experts qui
dit qu'il faut laisser faire l'immunité
comme en grande bretagne c'est l'expert
clinique au complet on sait l'experte me
dis qu'il faut pratiquer les têtes
donc c'est bien nos politiques de
choisir c'est d'ailleurs la règle d'être
profond du politique il y avait un
pilotage automatique autant laisser
l'obturateur diriger la pente n'était
pas possible
la deuxième raison fondamentale et que
finalement il s'agit toujours dans ce
réflexe un peu technocratique
corporatiste des les gens qui nous
dirigent de se cacher derrière une
autorité au su alors à la fois pour
ouvrir un parapluie on se comprend bien
sûr pas nous qui avons décidé le comité
d'experts et aussi parce que finalement
cette classe dirigeante mettons les
guinéens et hellip les camps et guinée
elle a été sélectionnée forme et non pas
sur des critères de décision politique
n'est précisément sur les critères de
gestion
et l'administration un administratif un
gestionnaire que quelqu'un il va
rapporter à une autorité supérieure
quelqu'un qui va se fonder sur des
précédents et qui va chercher finalement
une solution qui existe déjà mais
précisément c'est papa la politique la
politique c'est faire face à
l'imprévisible faire papale implantables
et quand il ya un président y est les
l'impensable précisément il n'y a rien
dans les manuels
il n'y a rien dans la gestion n'y a rien
on les précédentes pour traiter le
problème
alors du coup en quoi cette crise
finalement va changer le rapport des
français à la politique selon vous je
pense de manière assez fort qu elle va
aboutir à un changement de têtes
dirigeantes
parce que d'abord il ya des raisons des
réflexes conditionnés
je lui laisse d'ailleurs il ya vraiment
une dimension de gestion et à la fois la
haute fonction publique un l'ena et
femmes et c'est aussi finalement un
paradigme un modèle qui est le modèle
anglo-saxon du management qui était
complètement digérée par l'énarchie
franc pèse et le modèle de management
que dit il il ne faut pas faire de
stocks le justin taille il faut tout à
produire en chine parce que ça coûte
moins cher fait la rationalité fait les
modèles économiques on l'a vendu
ce modèle économique que dit-il encore
il vient il dit finalement que
l'économie doit tout driver doit tout
diriger et donc on voit bien ce système
on pète prend l'eau de toutes parts
l'idée d'europe ça a été suffisamment
suffisamment dit et répété mais
finalement l'élément le plus stratégique
éléments le prix politique dans le
couple edouard philippe emmanuel la
conque c'est tout de même l'idée de
faire ce sont vers une dimension père
albert constituer un état européen est
d'ailleurs le président n'en démord pas
finalement ça ne fonctionne pas mais le
prénom doit aller encore plus loin dans
le rock on voit bien qu'à une monnaie il
n'y a pas de budget n'y a pas d'état il
y aura mille budget état parce qu'il
n'ya pas de peuple
merci beaucoup guillaume bigot d'avoir
partagé votre analyse rappelle que cette
politologue et essayiste